عند اجراء اول تجربه لصاروخ الصرمات
الباليست في ابريل الماضي قال الرئيس
الروسي فلاديمير بوتين ان هذا الصاروخ
سيجعل اعداء روسيا يتوقفون ويفكرون يزن
صاروخ صارمات الذي قال الرئيس انه لا مثيل
له ولن يكون له مثيل فتره طويله من الزمن
220 طنا ويبلغ طوله اكثر من 35 مترا يبلغ
مداهما بين عشره الاف وثمانيه عشر الف
كيلو متر ما يجعله قادرا على ضرب اي بقعه
في الارض يستطيع حمل عشره رؤوس النوويه
ويمكنه اطلاق حموله قصوى تبلغ 50 ميجا طن
من ماده تي ان تي
صمم صاروخ صرمات للافلات من انظمه الدفاع
المضاده للصواريخ من خلال تقنيات لا تمنح
هذه الانظمه الا وقتا قصيرا لبدء التتبع
في مقابل هذا الصاروخ تطور الولايات
المتحده منذ 2014 صاروخا عابر للقارات
يتوقع ان يفوق مدى هذا الصاروخ
5500 كيلومتر ويستطيع الوصول الى اي هدف
في الارض خلال 30 دقيقه سيتم تزويد
الصاروخ براس النووي حربي ويستطيع الصاروخ
اطلاق الراس النووي في منتصف الطريق
لينطرق الراس في اتجاه الهدف يتوقع ان
تجرى اول تجربه لهذا الصاروخ الامريكي عام
2023 وان يدخل الخدمه عام 2029
[موسيقى]